PROFESSOR: Hi everybody.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture you did a bunch
of examples of related rates
problems.
So I have a couple more
for you to do today.
So here we've got--
OK, so we've got
air being blown into
a spherical balloon
at a rate of 1,000 cubic
centimeters per second.
So the question is,
how fast is the radius
growing when the radius
is equal to 8 centimeters?
And then OK, so I've got
a second question, which
is, how fast is the surface
area growing at that same time?
So why don't you take
a few minutes, work
this one out for
yourself, come back,
and we'll work it out together.
All right.
Welcome back.
So this question, like all
related rates questions,
has the property that
the calculus is typically
very straightforward,
but that there's
some geometric or
algebraic setup.
So in this case, it's
straight up geometry.
So we have a balloon, we
know it's a perfect sphere,
we know how fast the
volume is changing.
So OK, but we need to know how
fast the radius is changing.
So in order to do that
we need to figure out
a relationship between
the radius and the volume.
And then we can just do
implicit differentiation
like we've been doing.
So for example, OK,
so for a sphere--
the setup is not so bad
for this first one--
so we know that for a sphere the
volume is equal to 4/3 pi times
the radius cubed.
So that's the fundamental
relationship between the volume
and radius of a sphere, and
it's true for every sphere
everywhere in Euclidean space.
And we're given
also, that the volume
is changing at a constant rate
of 1,000 centimeters cubed
per second.
So dV/dt is just
given to be 1,000.
You know, leave off the
units at this point.
So the question
is, what is dr/dt?
That's what we're
trying to figure out.
We're trying to figure
out how fast the radius is
changing at the moment
when the radius is
equal to 8 centimeters.
So how can we do that?
Well, this fundamental
relationship, it's an identity.
It always holds.
So that means we can
differentiate it.
So if we take the
derivative of this identity,
well, V on the left
just becomes dV/dt.
And on the right we want to
do implicit differentiation.
So here r is changing
with respect to time.
r is a function of t.
Well, OK.
So 4/3 pi is a constant.
So that when we differentiate
nothing happens.
4/3 pi.
And so now we differentiate
r cubed with respect to t,
so that gives us 3 r
squared times dr/dt.
So that's just the chain
rule in action there.
And now what we
want is this dr/dt.
Right?
That's the thing that
we're looking for, is
how fast the radius is growing.
So that's dr/dt.
And we want it at the
moment when r is equal to 8.
So when r is equal to 8,
this implies that-- well, OK,
so dV/dt is 1,000 always.
And it implies that--
OK, so it's equal to,
1,000 is equal to 4/3 pi times
3 times 8 squared times dr/dt.
So at this moment that
we're interested in,
we have this equation
to solve, for dr/dt,
and this is a nice,
simple equation to solve.
You just divide
through by everything
on the right-hand
side other than dr/dt.
So this implies that dr/dt
is equal to-- well, OK,
so I have to divide
1,000 by all this stuff.
I think it works out to
something like 125 over 32*pi.
All right.
So that's the exact value.
Maybe you're interested
in sort of knowing
about how large this is.
So 32*pi is pretty close to 100,
so this is about 1.2 something.
So, all right.
So there we go.
So that answers
the first question.
At that moment the radius is
growing at a rate of 125 over
32*pi centimeters per second.
OK.
So now how about the second
question that we've got here?
What about the surface area?
So again, we know how fast
now the radius is changing
and we know how fast
the volume is changing.
So in order to figure out
how fast the surface area is
changing, we need something
that relates the surface
area to either the
volume or the radius.
Now the relationship between
surface area and volume
is something that we could
sort of work out if we had to,
but it's a lot easier to
write down the surface
area in terms of the radius.
So let's do that.
So we have, I'm going to
use the letter S to denote
surface area of a sphere.
So again, it's a general
identity, you know,
a geometric fact that the
surface area of a sphere is
equal to 4*pi times
the radius squared.
And this is always true.
And now the thing that
we want is the rate
of change of the surface area.
So the rate of change
is the derivative.
So we want to compute the
derivative here, dS/dt.
So OK, so we just do it.
So dS/dt is equal to--
well, 4*pi hangs around.
And again, we
differentiate r squared.
r is a function of t, so we
have to use the chain rule here.
So this is times 2r times dr/dt.
So this is an identity.
So this is true always.
And now we want to know, at
this particular moment in time,
when r is equal to
8, what is ds/dt?
And in order figure that
out, well OK, we just
have to be able to plug
in for everything else.
So when r equals 8--
all right, well luckily,
you know, if we were just
starting this problem
from scratch here,
we'd have a problem.
Which is we wouldn't
know what dr/dt was.
But luckily, we've already
figured it out, right?
In the first part
of the problem.
So we know that when
r is equal to 8,
dr/dt is equal to
125 over 32*pi.
Did I copy that right?
Yes, I did.
OK.
So OK, so in this case, the
equation we have to solve
is just completely
straightforward.
We just plug in the values and
it's already solved for us.
So that's nice.
So that we get that ds/dt at
that moment is equal to-- well,
it's 4*pi times 2 times 8 is
the radius times 125 over 32*pi.
Oh boy, and all right.
So we can work this out
if we want, I guess.
That's 32*pi to cancel,
so that's equal to 250.
And I guess the units there
better be centimeters squared
per second.
So at this moment in
time the surface area
is growing by 250 centimeters
squared per second.
So that's all we had to do.
So we're all set.